this is a production of cornell
university
i'd like to talk about some of the
things i've done for data analytics and
system optimization sort of extension to
some of the work we've talked about in
the workshop
and my original title was in sustainable
agricultural and plant breeding and
after talking with more people i decided
to broaden up to sustainability
and
the purpose today is really to introduce
some of the things that i have done in
my career and sample a few projects
that i've done related to agriculture to
get the discussion going the purpose is
really not to educate you for anything
i've included some reference here but i
want to get some conversation going in
terms of this direction
and hopefully get some thinking juice
going and i'm only like two hours away
so if you want to come down to visit rit
i'll be happy to host
with that
let's go ahead and get started i put in
one slide infomercial
because i'm the department head of the
department
i was talking to a couple
faculty director in the atkinson center
for sustainability here on campus just
right before um
my presentation now so we have a very
similar structure um although i think
there are differences as well
we have a building here this is called
golisano institute
for sustainability and it operates like
a college we have tenure line inside
that institute
and my department is called department
of sustainability
in my department we have two sort of
academic programs master program we
don't have undergraduate programs we
have master program in sustainable
system and phd program in sustainability
and i've listed these are some of the
core courses here we have in the program
we are very quantitative focused and
we teach courses such as industry
ecology
environmental risk analysis i teach
economics and we have
faculty from public policy and i also
teach multi-criteria decision
making and optimization that's actually
the course i'm teaching right now this
semester
in terms of faculty research
um the majority of my faculty actually
come from
engineering
with
a couple other from the social side
so we work on energy models policy
energy for development in countries
agriculture and food waste but more
sort of an urban environment one of my
faculty member kelly she has a project
supported by nsf working on some of the
regional like a restaurant how you
collect the waste and recycle circular
economy in the food sector
and then sustainable economics like your
cell phone every couple years you decide
to upgrade right so how do you use the
components in this cell phone to make
use of it
uh let's see this one
i
i didn't know you're going to introduce
me in this detail so i'll quickly talk
about my my background
i'm originally from china so
international i got my phd and master
from pittsburgh which is not that far
away it's actually closer to cornell
than to iowa and over the years
i've
the major of my career is at iowa state
so you'll probably keep me talking about
iowa state and
since
yesterday i've noticed that a lot of
iowa state connection on cornell campus
oddly enough but anyway so that makes me
more comfortable so my primary
appointment at iowa state was industrial
and manufacturing systems engineering
and but
i love to collaborate so over the years
i've been affiliated with
this is graduate program for sustainable
agricultural and bei is by economy
institute because i've done some work
related to
biofuel and processing
system analysis
this is bioinformatics and computational
biology well i do some genetics
and um mike you mentioned the psi
scholar is a very unique program at iowa
state it operates like an in doubt type
of position they give you
a reasonable amount of money for you to
spend wherever you want but on research
okay
and and last year i decided to take a
position up at uh um rochester institute
of technology and the department is very
unique in sustainability
and let's see
this was a group picture
taken
before covet so no mask yet
and my area is in operations research
and mathematics monitoring and as i was
talking to some of you i said what i
didn't know about
agricultural before i joined iowa state
and i was in one meeting
people were talking about maze and i
said what what is mace i didn't know
that may is the same as core
so um one thing i was talking to some of
you is that i'm good at asking pretty
dumb questions so i would expect a much
better question from this audience
but anyway over the years i've
i've been educated in the agricultural
sector and i've enjoyed doing that rit
we don't have too much of ag other than
the local food system
recycling research so that's why after i
joined i said i have to figure out a way
to keep doing egg so i reached out to
michael and other people on campus here
at cornell and and we've been enjoying
the collaboration
i i like to talk about some other
collaborat applications because the
purpose of this is really exposed to
this group to more of other
sustainability research
and um i'm not trying to
change you from ag to other area but
basically get you exposed to some of
other things that i i was doing and
maybe that can even spark some
collaborations because of some of the
tools that i've been working on so i'll
use one slide or two each
in the next um section to talk about uh
what i've been working on so the first
one is supply chain design this is
actually something i did for my phd
pre manufacturing system
so um
we're looking at forward supply chain
and closed loop so basically circular
economy in the manufacturing sector what
i worked on was a pricing strategy and
inventory control
and this is a mathematic model i'm not
going to go to detail about the
mathematics about a project we did with
caterpillar and this is a
project that was funded by sf has the
center on center for
university and industry corporation and
this is a what's called center for
e-design and it's very unique uh setting
that actually set up the collaboration
between universities and
companies
so
i've worked on manufacturing and
production this is a very interesting
project that with the
collaboration with georgia tech this was
my iowa state years because i've only
joined rit in the last
10 months
and this is a project that we did
think about this as a
engine and we are taking data from the
manufacturing production floor um
yesterday i was talking to um
debbie um one of your posters over here
we are talking about how the different
system gets integrated and then this
type of system kind of can connect to
the agricultural they're different
components but anyway i'll talk more
when i'm talking about the ag component
so what we are doing here is integrate
this data in the real time setting
and my involvement there is a
decision-making engine that can
integrate the data and spit out
real-time decision support information
that can feed to
redesign a dashboard because we have two
small
software company actually we developed a
software and now it's in the commercial
production um
and another thing unique we did is that
it's actually feed to the right what's
called sona right individual like in the
production floor you may have shop floor
manager you may have material
coordinator
but in the agricultural setting you have
farmers you have policy makers that can
maybe benefit from some of the decision
decision-making tools
energy systems
this is how i got into agriculture right
because i was enjoying doing
manufacturing and then
i was driving around iowa state and
there are a lot of corn soybean there so
i started
how how can i get involved into act and
then i bump into one professor in
mechanical engineering and his areas is
in biofuel so i said well that sounds
pretty cool
so then what we did was on some energy
system analysis this is a project we did
for department of energy where we look
at different types of production pathway
like for example think about corn stover
and you go through a heat transformation
process called pyrolysis then you have
some downstream process
so
we did
what's called techno-economic analysis
and life cycle assessment to evaluate
whether it's really environmental
friendly people may think oh
you know buy a few it has to be
environmental friendly i was talking to
neil this morning ca control environment
act you would think oh that's
environmental friendly
that may may or may not be the case so
we need to go through the analytical
process to really evaluate
the environmental impact and also what
is really making money right a lot of
energy input
into this production process as well as
cea i was in the greenhouse this morning
um
do you know what this is
algae yeah so um i was talking to john
look yesterday on zoom and he was
working on health right so a kelp the
sugar kelp so i think
these type of technology are
very popular in the energy conversion
i'm not going to go into too much detail
on this but what i did was a system that
we did process simulation and use that
data to
do economic analysis life cycle
assessment and this is something that
sort of court what i'm interested in in
terms of for example when
dupont pioneer is trying to decide
where to locate a facility you need to
think about where do you get the
original biomass and what do you source
the downstream product right so it's a
supply chain problem and this left it
was a usda project where we are looking
at
how we sort of close the loop right
there ecosystem services and there are
all kinds of factors you could consider
when you are designing the um
the process
uh sustainable agriculture there we go
over here um
i must say i don't know much you know
i'm just touching a very small component
this picture shows a project that we did
for usda we'll look at
how we understand the phenotype here i
put porn because i don't know anything
more than that but i know here cornell
we are more much more inclusive and
diverse right we are all kinds of crops
um
so this is basic framework we are
looking at how genotype and environment
join it determine the phenotype this can
be yield prediction this can be um other
type of intermediate trait flowering
time plant height you know whatever you
measure and we are throwing a mansion
piece but people are talking about g by
e right so there's g by e by m so how do
you take the data driven approach to
understand
um
the data and then what's the inherent
relationship between the input and
output so there's sort of three levels
of
analysis
descriptive you have historic data you
are trying to make sense of it right and
then predictive
we have historic data we have some
future information how do we going to
predict what's happening this coming
next year when we have some weather
forecast
and prescriptive it's really saying
when we have some information how do we
design the optimal strategy or neutral
management strategy
or apple tree treatment strategy right
there are all kinds of things that we
can do
that can change the outcome now the
question is that how do we find out the
optimal strategy
so that's what the optimization can come
in and i'll talk more about that in my
sort of three i've included three small
pieces of work um
precision egg and optimization
i did a paper with a couple colleagues
at iowa state where we started the
concept of
farm by soil and then we did irrigation
planning iowa we don't irrigate but we
did a case study for california
um do we irrigate here upstate new york
oh really okay i know nebraska and some
other but
um we also did um a paper look at seed
selection
when to plant and what to plant and what
kind of
mixture so it's a sort of farm
management um and then there are other
things that we are looking at
um
and this is the bioinformatics and
computational biology i'm not going to
go into detail because i have one that's
focusing on this and then we design a
data collection and a visualization
strategy
two slides on health scale
coverage sort of gave me interesting
healthcare related work on data
analytics and this is a project that i
did with university of iowa physician
it's same thing you have input and
output you're trying to understand the
relationship and we did another paper
related to coleman 19
and i for those students out there
i like to put my student out there and
compete in challenges so we compete in
the syngenta craft challenge how many
people know this in general crop
challenge so you know
but this is a coin 19 pandemic response
challenge so they give out real data out
there and you can work on it so my
students work on it and then we were
selected as one of the finalists and
basically for me we write papers right
so
um
so i like to use the rest of the time to
talk about um a three piece of small
work that we've done related to
sustainable agriculture and just again
get some discussion going
the first one is
um
so curious i i think in one of the
conversation that was brought up
we in the workshop three years ago he
was here as well and mohsen was one of
my phd students
anyway in this study we were covering
machine learning and cloud monitoring to
help yield prediction
and um as a quick introduction so for
yield prediction there are sort of two
mainstream one is more of a data driven
approach we have historic data we're
trying to use a data-driven model to
relay the input and output
and then the simulation approach is more
up from the crop physiological
perspective you have the sunshine you
have different stages you accumulate the
biomass okay so there are pros and cons
of each of them
but so far it has been
sort of uh
researched separately so what we are
trying to do because so tyrion's his
areas is in the crop simulation is doing
epsom and all of those so we think there
is benefit of integrated together
and this slide summarize the pros and
cons so for example for the prof
simulation approach
the accuracy is reasonable and but it
needs a specific skill set that's crop
related and it tends to be time
consuming because of the
computational efficiency and also
computational requirement with respect
to um to the simulation right kelly we
were talking about that yesterday and
they tend to have
long running time machine learning wide
range of application
accuracy tend to be high if you have
enough data
now
the biggest problem is transparency
black box
you don't know how to interpret it and
then even if it's a very nice accuracy
you don't know why
just always say trust me it's it's good
but farmers practitioners
how could i
you know bad my decision-making program
um on this type of non-transparent
approach so for this specific paper what
we did was we have yield data weather
soy and management data and this this
top is the machine learning approach and
then the bottom line is crop monitoring
what we are doing is certairis group his
speed out some of the intermediary trade
information and that's fast and also
easy
and we were able to grab this
information and use it as an input for
our machine learning approach so it's a
very straightforward idea
and we want to answer a few questions
first does this hybrid approach we've
tried some other
hybrid approach as well but we want to
check whether this hyper approach is
going to help with
what we did corn but crop yield
prediction in general and second what's
the right setup what's the right
combination and also what are some of
the traits that are important what are
some of the factors that are important
for us to understand this so these are
some of the absent features that
incorporated um
from
okay just i have the pointer
these are the phenology related crop
related soy and weather related um i
think i'm sort of preaching to the fire
i probably don't need to explain all the
features but basically these are
provided by my collaborator
explain to me
and then the data said we got the usda
data set the predictors are from appsim
and then
from
usda nas database we have the plant
population
planting date basic plant in progress
percentage and also weather and soil
information and then the target are corn
yield for we did three states and we
also did another 12 states for the
entire corn belt
and
data preprocessing and model selection
i'm not going to go to too much detail
because of the time but basically there
is a feature construction feature
selection and although for the model
selection we took a bayesian approach
in terms of the cross validation
if you are interested in knowing more we
can have follow up conversation and we
have a couple of publications on this
so um in terms of
the data pre-processing we construct a
feature called yield trend
to capture the general trend of the
relationship in the um in the data set
because there's this assumption that as
time goes that because of technology
because of the the genotype that there's
a general increasing trend
and then we want to capture that
so one slide on the results
so the
the y-axis is the testing relative room
mean square error so testing roomy
square error means we are testing on the
data that the model has not seen so
there's training accuracy there's
testing accuracy
and then the x-axis these are different
types of models some of them are more
transparent than other some of the
ensemble based and we i'm not going to
too much detail but some of them are
optimization based where we design some
mechanism to optimize the
ensemble mechanism
the point i want to make here is that
the top is the benchmark so for the
relative relative roommate square error
the lower the battery right it's a
percentage error you can think about it
as a percentage error so the top part is
the benchmark is
the method we have not the the result
well we don't integrate absent input
right so and then the bottom one is same
model but we incorporate absent input
for the testing accuracy we know that
from a machine learning perspective if
we're talking about training accuracy
the more data you always get better
accuracy but now for testing accuracy
this is where you test the real accuracy
and we can see that across the board
when you have the
crop based physiological or
crop based input you include improve the
accuracy
and this is x y plot this x is the
actual yield and y is the predicted and
this is the 45 degree line trust it is a
4 it doesn't look like a 45 degree line
because i got it stretched but it's a
real 45 degree line top four pictures
are the
um benchmark and then the bottom one is
the hybrid approach just to
put in perspective
so um
we we've
we've seen that their improvement across
the board by up to 25
29
and we found out that most important
apps include soil water and also some
other factors
so
with that i will go oh this is the paper
that got published so if you want to
check it out
the second
piece of work
that
i want to share is
a machine learning approach for soybean
saturn death syndrome
detection and we
darren is a
professor in plant pathology and then
yuva is a postdoc
and
we will lose using satellite imaging
okay so um
i guess i'm preaching to the why plant
disease is important to investigate i'm
not going to go into this a point i want
to make over here is that
sds in soybean it's very difficult to
detect
it's variable in time space and also
genotype right so um the way right now
they detect is you walk you're scouting
the field and then you try to detect
them early enough but
if we can automate the process that
would be better so these are some of the
techniques
that can be used for sensing
techniques but these are what's called
neosensing so you look at the
picture the first one is look at the
temperature and then color
and then this is you know hyperspectrum
okay so there are
different types of existing method that
you can use to
for sensing for this research what we
are interested in knowing is that
what if we zoom out
so the near sense is that you look at
this piece of leak the soybean leaf and
you see how
how yellow it is right and then all the
yellowing pattern
now what we are seeing is what we are
saying is that in order to really um
improve the efficiency
and also cover a large area
we need to go to what's called remote
sensing i know you guys are flying the
drone right so this is really remote um
so remote sensing there is uh uav there
is tractor mounted
tool
this specific paper we're using
satellite imaging you may ask me why
the reason is that we have the data
and
and another reason is that it's cheaper
if you have the system set up because um
for these you need to fly it every time
you fly it there's a cost and for this
you need to drive through but this it's
a it's a sort of uh stationary but the
downside is that resolution is much
smaller it's much lower for the
satellite
um so we did a couple method one is
called sequence based method because for
soybean saturn that syndrome once it's
once you've seen there is it's always
going to be there so once you turn from
zero to one it will stay at one
okay so we've we've designed some
sequence based approach and non-sequence
based approach sort of neural network
and also statistical learning approach
um
i guess i'm not going to go to the
mathematics but the point here is it's
time stamped
lstm so long short
time memory based approach but it's a
it's a reduced version of that for
computational efficiency
it's called gate and recurrent units
and this table summarizes the results so
we've done different types of analysis
these lists out
for analysis and gru extreme boost and
and fully record fully connected
your network so as you can see the
you may think of the improvement is
marginal but when i when we were talking
to the practitioners this is actually
quite significant improvement because
it's very hard to improve the accuracy
so my point is that by having some
innovation incorporate some data-driven
approach um it can actually help
improve the accuracy
given the limit because the resolution
we have in this study was three meter by
three middle three meter by three meter
is one pixel so it's very very low
resolution um if you pay you can get 72
centimeter by 72 centimeter you know but
we did not have the money but anyway my
point is that if you have the money you
can get higher resolution and probably
better results
but that's a sort of good first
step and then it was published a couple
years ago
the last piece of work probably most
related to
um reading um is uh genomic selection
okay so i hope i have not lost the
audience yet but we have good presence
online 45 people great um so this is
a streamline of work that um
i've collaborated with passionate who is
the psi director at iowa state and then
lee who was here three years ago as well
did the workshop so we
did simulation optimization and
reinforcement learning in genomic
selection
so uh let me
just quickly talk about
i guess this room we all know about
genomic selection
okay
because i don't think everyone is in the
room
okay so i will i will i will do i hope
uh yeah
because i'm not an expert and when you
explain things that you don't you're not
the expert on in front of experts
sometimes i feel a little bit
embarrassed but i'll try okay
so um so this slide is summarized the
traditional approach is phenotypical you
go to the field look at let's say you
want to select for
top corner right higher
you that's called phenotypical selection
genomic selection saying that you
genotype it and based on historic data
you can have genomic prediction model so
that's why we overlay some zero one snip
information in the background
and then by doing that you basically
predict what is going to happen if you
make the selection
and um so in this case the phenol
typical selection if you are selecting
the top point you may select the top two
over here right so the
genomics selection is saying that well
because of we have genomic information
and historic data we may be better off
selecting this too okay
so um that's sort of the difference
between you know typical selection and
genomic selection and genomic selection
at the top we have training population
and phenotype and genotype then you have
a genomic prediction model i know a lot
of people here are working on genomic
prediction model and then in the real
breeding process you have breeding
population and genotype you apply the
prediction model you predict what's
going to happen and that can speed up
the breeding process that's the hope
right you can speed up the breeding
process
my goal or our
goal is
we are now trying to
improve the front of course a lot of
research can be done this specific
streamline for work is to help improve
the selection and mating strategy
so who to selected to and what to mate
with who
we switch what's the female and what's
the man okay so that's what we are doing
in the um in this study
and um
this is a schematic one example of
genomic selection over three generations
generation one two and three
and then i'm using a very short um
you know
geno stream to represent one individual
so we have
12 individuals on the top
the question is which ones to select and
how do we pair it up so we have two
inter-crossing over here and generate
this population and then this is
inter-crossing and then for core we can
do back crossing right
back crossing basically you are crossing
to the previous generation and you can
do intercrossing you can also do selfie
right because
male and female
now
the purpose is
how do we select which one to cross with
which one and after a limited number of
generations
you will get a superior population that
we're going to be selecting for
genetic gain
and the problem definition here is that
given the initial population how many
and which
uh individuals to proceed
how many progeny
should be produ produced for each class
basically
their resource consequences right
produ produce you can produce they're
basically the same but the point is that
how many you end up genotype for next
generation and then you keep going that
the challenge is that there are large
number of alleles um
for this study we had
pad had
1.3 million snips but we know the core
genome is much much larger
and their varying contribution of the
alleles the zeros and ones
and recombination possibilities is a
probabilistic event right into crossing
and then there are budget and deadline
constraints
so for this we were working with
syngenta and
cotiva on some of the
analysis
and we had one paper on what's called
look ahead uh reading look at selection
approach so the goal is to maximize
expected
gbv for a terminal generation let's say
10 generation down the road or however
generation you are interested in
targeting so the inputs are the
genotype recombination frequency and
also time constraints right how many
generations you are looking for into the
future the output are selection
strategies and also the mating strategy
so there's a mathematic model behind it
and uh because of the probabilistic
event
um we we're not able to solve to
optimality so we take a simulation
optimization approach
so this framework is quite uh high level
so you're trying to maximize the
target terminal generation um
phenotypical value and then you have
certain type of selection decision
making variable
and
the way we do it is that there is a
probabilistic
decision making framework and then we
let's say we are generation lower t
we are looking into the target
generation and there is a simulation
optimization approach that can look far
into the future and then by looking at
this we'll be able to guide our
selection and mating strategy for
generation lowercase t
okay so that's what's behind look ahead
because you are looking to the future
generation and chase back what's the
right strategy
by doing that we were able to
get genetic gain as well as maintain
genetic diversity because we know that
it's critical important to have that for
our future
need
and this we all know that it's a problem
probabilistic event so the way we did is
we run the simulation 1000 times
and this is what's called cumulative
distribution curve right because when
you run it 1000 times there's some
distribution
now let me just point you the x-axis is
the genetic gain y is the percentile so
you can look at the 50 that's about the
average genetic gain
and we are comparing
the look ahead greeting strategy with
the other strategies so this is the
conventional genomic selection right you
look at the gedv and then make this
truncation selection
and then you have the ohv and then opv
which is another paper we did as well
but the point is that the far right it
is the better the curve
the better the selection strategy is so
as you can see at least from this um
work the look ahead reading um or
selection strategy is outperforming the
other existing method
and this was published a couple years
ago
so we did an extension so the previous
look ahead selection is that we're just
looking at a single chip
let's say yield right
and
now when we talk to our
collaborators who say oh you know we
want to look at multiple trades right
what if we want to maximize yield at the
same time we want to keep the height
within the range because you don't want
it to be too hot too tall it may lead to
lodging and you don't want it too short
anyway
so um
the traditional approach is index
selection right you sort of for their
tandem selection as well we did
comparison for the paper
now for the
this paper has been published i i didn't
include too many specifics over here but
basically we
extend the look ahead selection approach
by incorporating multiple trades
and
and we demonstrated it's better than the
traditional index selection approach
the last piece of work or the last
extension is
reinforcement learning because the
problem for some of these um
genomic selection is that
the
possibility is all the decision making
state
space is huge because you think about
you can have all kinds of combinations
inter crossing mating
and
the what's called decision space it can
be exponentially increasing
now what we are doing for the
reinforcement learning is that
we basically have um
the state space
and also we are using your network to
approximate the input output
relationship in the breeding strategy
input as well as the genetic gain output
and then we are feeding that into the
simulation
without going into too much detail
we basically did a vapor this is a
collaboration with syngenta and one of
my phd students
we just got the paper published a couple
weeks ago
to summarize
um
back to my topic
data analytics and system optimization
right i i gave you a few
examples but really your own research
you can think about because my
background is industrial engineering by
training so i know how to look at from
the system level but really the way i
perceive is that you know machine
learning and predictive analysis can be
of significant value
but we really need to think about first
what is the research question
and second in order to
really do things that people care about
and make sense i think what's called
multi-scale so for example when you're
zooming into the genomic selection
you're talking about single plant or
a
plants but when you zoom out
there are some interconnections there
and it's important to make this
connection so that it's a system that's
going to be
efficient and effective when we really
deploy it out there in the field
and um
okay so
these are some acknowledgement with that
i will stop here because
i think
sustainability is very big and vague and
people are all talking about that i know
i'm making a very small contribution to
it but we all need to chime in and help
but
how we can help
what kind of input we can provide i
think it depends on what kind of
knowledge base you have but
um as i was talking to some of you my
general experience as being as long as
you are open-minded
and genuinely interested in what the
other side is interested doing i'm sure
you can make an impact and make your own
contribution okay so with that i will
stop and leave the rest of time for
questions thank you
let me talk so we have
about 10 minutes
yeah
why don't we let a graduate student ask
so
the three
broader projects that you were the three
questions you were talking about
and would be really interesting and i'm
um
interested in
knowing more about how much you
integrate those three and how far
in the future you do like probably i
think like you have the giveaway by um
country
somehow integrated certain agriculture
data and then also view genomic
selection with the data you obtain
um so i was wondering how far in the
future you use all those techniques to
let's say um
you predict the yield for chlorine
um which like currently increases but
let's say if you integrate in
solidification potentially it might
decrease at some point in the further
future um so how do we
integrate the data that we know
how do we integrate those
the knowledge into our our
decisions now to select let's say plans
that are not going to suffer in like one
soil is depleted or do you also
integrate like genomic data
it's just so much about it
yeah um
that's a great question and it's a
loaded question
so if i don't fully uh answer that feel
free to follow up um
we are trying to integrate because we
have an sf project
that
i the title is crop improvement
under changing environment
so um
to answer your question right now we
haven't done much
because for example for the genomic
selection we are so zooming to
understand how do we make how do we get
that genetic gain
and
one thing we discover is some of the
mechanism can preserve
genetic diversity
so that's in a way helping the future
improvement and and maybe under future
changing environment
uh your second point in terms of the
precision farm management
one thing what we are doing is um
we incorporate some input from farmers
because iowa state has extension just
like cornell over here so we collect
some input from farmer and incorporate
that into the what's called precision
farm management
i must say
it's not easy to implement
we've had some online tools and i'm sure
when you work with renewal and nutrient
management there are all kinds of
obstacles
i don't have a quick easy solution we i
think we all need to work towards how we
integrate them together but i think
the first step of implementation is to
bring awareness and also
make
the knowledge easily grasped by the
practitioner practitioners farmers or
whoever out there for extension
and by doing that you can gradually
infuse some of the techniques and
knowledge and some of the
sort of next generation pharma we talked
to they're actually very open for data
analytics and optimization mechanism
but now the question is that
do we have to
right uh
skill set to educate them and are we
speaking the same language and there are
a lot of things that needs to be
addressed in order to have a fully
implementable system that's going to
make a difference in real practice
does that sort of answer your question
okay
see the audience
oh
anyone else i was wondering the
optimization of
the patch novel on the gas is there
anything counter-intuitive that the
model came up with
like much larger populations different
crossing designs that
or was it mostly
fine tuning of what we already
have here
um
so for the conventional genomic
selection i didn't include
the plot of genetic diversity you'll
notice that
the conventional genomic selection
the
genetic diversity increase or i'm sorry
decrease dramatically so basically you
are
you are
converting to a very
um
very um
what's the right word uh the the genetic
uh diversity in the terminal population
is very limited and we notice that we
didn't intentionally
target on the genetic diversity but by
doing that by sort of looking a little
bit further ahead somehow the model is
smart enough to learn that preserving
genetic diversity is important when we
are looking a little bit further into
the future and then chase back so
i i personally think that's a very
interesting observation although we all
know that oh we need to preserve genetic
diversity but be able to
see that
without explicitly incorporating that as
objective function
it's it's very interesting
um but in terms of the specific genetics
i cannot call because i don't know much
about that but but yeah that's a great
question i think they are
they're definitely things that
i when i was working with my
collaborator we say oh this is the
results and they say oh that makes sense
but then there are certain things they
say hmm that doesn't make sense but
after thinking through that well that's
actually teaching us something so i
think this type of approach when you
really sit down and and now work through
the process i think both sides are
learning something
and what is that something you have to
go through it in order to really learn
that
great talk um i'm wondering about the
fiction optimization model if there's
any work
going on to make you more
oh the optimization yes so it would have
like dual purpose of like predicting
something
but also kind of have a more understated
are you talking about the prediction
model are you talking about the the
optimization because the the prediction
model
it's more of a data analytics right it's
data driven approach
the underlying is still optimization but
we are not explicitly optimizing certain
practice you're basically trying to
maximize the prediction accuracy that's
all
so are you asking about how
okay um
they are this concept of physics
informed
deep learning basically what that is is
when you are designing the new network
or data-driven model
you are incorporate
expert knowledge into the decision it's
not in your decision-making into the
data-driven approach for example
let's say if i know certain crop
physiological inputs are following
certain relationship then you can impose
a constraint
into the data-driven model and by doing
that
you are
improving the transparency because now
you can say that well this set of
constraints is incorporating
the physics for
the crop physiological process
but if you're talking about the last
piece optimization that's actually quite
transparent
it's just i did not spend time to
explain but
optimization you have objective function
constraints and then you have decision
variables decision variables are what
you can change constraints are the
physiological or physics bound that you
have to abide
basic follow right those are the
constraints objective functions
basically what you are trying to
optimize whether it's maximizing profit
or minimizing environmental impact those
all have physical meaning
okay i think you are first yeah
so it's a great presentation so i have
listened to a couple of podcasts which
says agriculture is an optimization
problem right now because to
reach a food security and a growing
population we have top based resources
to grow that so
i had a big idea at that time but now i
have a better better understanding than
that a very great presentation on this
one so i just have a couple of questions
on the satellite
projects that you've worked on yeah so
in the satellite projects are you
working the county scale or the field
so the data we have um it's some
experimental sites so
it's not county skill it's just basic
experiment size my collaborator darren
he has
and um like i said the resolution is
three meter by three meter three meter
by three meter is just one pixel we have
three numbers rgb values and that you're
using that to to predict so it's very
low resolution and then the field
i think we have
8 to 12 pixels for each small plot and
that's all the data we have access to
but we have about
120 ish plots
yeah and about the crop yield prediction
you didn't use any remote sensing data
there or did you use any
for this specific paper i talked about
no but we have a follow-up work um
we're using remote sensing so you can
you can incorporate that yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
that's an excellent question so life
cycle assessment um
the first thing you you need to define
is what's the boundary you have to
define the boundary right now at the
boundary then you need to think about
what's going out what's coming in so
once you've designed the define the
boundary then you have the mechanism of
account for the input and output into
this bonded system that you can do the
analysis i would say that's the first
thing but when you are comparing across
the system i would say try to have some
consistency what we did for the
life cycle assessment for biofuel it's
very um
limited we are looking at
basically we're using bench scale data
in the lab but we scale it up to the
common practice of two thousand times
per day facility
we're using simulation to scale it up we
have the capital investment operating
expense input output chemical process
and that can generate the material flow
and everything and then that's the
boundary that we've defined so there's
some consistency across the different
production pathway but at end day you
need to define this is the boundary that
um that i'm i'm dealing with
and for in general a general comment
about system modeling or optimization is
that you need to
clearly list out assumptions so all
models are wrong some are useful but
it's very important to say
this is the assumption that i'm making
and you can disagree
with my assumption but but then you
update your own assumption i can make
updates right but as long as you clearly
list out these are the assumptions that
go into the model i think that would be
fine
great question yeah
okay
one last question
great presentation yeah have questions
so um
one of your work was coupling both uh
machine learning and crop model so how
did that work so did the output that you
know came from the crop model go into
the machine learning yeah
yeah you can you can think about other
ways too
because we tried a variety of them but
this turned out to be working pretty
nicely for the data set
i think the different ways in terms of
what you incorporate and how you
incorporate and and what kind of because
you can have a separate component and we
have some papers on that you know one
component or one new network for weather
one your network for the genetics and
one unique for um the some other factors
by that you that can increase some
transparency because you can say this
component it's for these factors
although inside it is still black box
but that can increase some transparency
so there are all kinds of things you can
you can apply but this specific paper we
did not yeah
yeah
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu